Hi everyone.
Today I'll tell you how to grow your
own Babel Fish.
So it turns out that the metaphor is
not really that original, especially if you've
seen Sam
stock from IBM Watson, but I'll briefly describe
what
the Babel Fish is.
Babel Fish is unfortunately
a fictional animal from Hitchhiker's Guide
to the Galaxy
by Douglas Adams, and according to the author
it is
a small yellow leech-like, and probably the
oddest thing
in the universe.
It feeds on brainwave energy and long
story short, it is a universal translator.
The main
problem is you actually have to stick one
into your ear
to make it work, but once you do it, you'll
understand
anything that is said to you in any language.
If you
haven't read the book, I really recommend
you do.
Okay,
so moving on.
About two years ago I become
interested in WebRTC.
Thomas will give a talk later
today, so I'll describe it really briefly.
It is an API
that allows you to create peer-to-peer connections
between devices, not necessarily just browsers,
and you
can basically send anything you want through
such
a connection: audio, video, or data.
About a year ago
I get a talk about interesting applications
of WebRTC
which was basically showing what stuff you
can build
with it, and I was looking for some applications
to
show, and the thing is that for data, there
are lots of
really interesting applications.
I mean, WebRTC
doesn't -- I mean the protocol is not based
on TCP, but
rather UDP, so we can do very low working,
you can do
file sharing because you have a direct connection
between two devices, you don't have to send
a file like
for example in Dropbox.
Maybe some of you have even
heard my application called shadrock(?) which
is like
airdrop, which ironically doesn't work on
safari, but
you can actually do crazy stuff with the data
translator, like implement protocol in JavaScript,
which
works in browser, and that's exactly what
WebRTC does.
But in the case of audio and video, things
are boring.
We have Skype for actually quite some time,
and, you
know, WebRTC does exactly the same but it
is not really
that interesting, right, so I didn't have
anything to
show and I decided to write my own application
with a
small technical twist, and that's what I'd
like to show
you today.
Okay.
So it is time for the demo.
So just
sit back, relax and enjoy.
demo played)
Okay, so
that's it.
[applause].
Thank you.
So as you can see it is basically a
universal translator as well, just like Babel
Fish.
The
thing is that on the left-hand side of your
video, yeah,
left, you can select the language you're speaking.
On
the right-hand side you can see what the language
the
other person speaks, in and there is one picture
that I
haven't really shown, is that if the speech
recognition
is completely messed up you can type the message
here
and it will also be translated and sent to
the other
person.
So it looks like kind of cool, right, but
it is
actually nothing new.
This is a screenshot from a Skype
translator by Microsoft.
It was released in December
last year and it does exact the same thing.
It does it
even better because in my application you
have to press
the button to turn the speech recognition
on.
I later
describe why it is necessary.
In this application you can just speak all
the time,
and it will all the time recognise what you're
saying.
There are some advantages over Skype.
The most
obvious one is that it works in the browser.
The Skype
application is obviously an application that
works only
on windows.
It uses open standards for WebRTC, Skype is
some proprietary protocols, but to be fair,
Microsoft is
currently working on a version of Skype that
will work
in the browser it will use in the next version
of
WebRTC, I'm not sure about Skype translator,
but at
least a normal version of Skype should work
in the
browser.
But the most important thing I want to say
is
that really, the first working version of
it took one
day to write.
And it really shows how powerful today's
browsers are and how powerful the APIs are.
And it is
really not that hard to write something like
that.
So
hopefully you're all wondering how it works.
So I'll go
over it step by step, warning there will be
some code
ahead, but not much fortunately so the first
thing is
obviously send audio and video, and it is
done via
WebRTC, so it is unfortunately not the simplest
and
easiest API, so I am using a library to make
it easier.
The library at the time is called simple WebRTC,
and
using it looks like this.
So that's like less than ten
lines of code and that's all you actually
need to make
your own Skype, or very basic version of Skype
application.
So I'll go it quickly.
First, you need to
instantiate it, then you just pass IDs of
DOM elements
where you want to display your video, and
video for
other people.
You wait for ready to call event, which
is when your browser gets access to your camera
and
microphone, and then you have to call to join
the room,
which will connect you to all the other peers
in the
same room.
That's actually the most complicated part
if
you'll use WebRTC directly, and that's just
one call in
simple WebRTC library.
Yeah, that's it.
We're actually down to the audio
and video part.
So, moving on to a bit more interesting
part, that is speech recognition.
It is done using web
speech recognition API, and using it looks
very similar
to the code that we've just seen.
Again, you have to
instantiate an object, you wait for a result
event which
will be triggered whenever the speech recognition
actually has some results, and finally you
go to the
start that will ask for your microphone and
start speech
recognition.
Okay, so the next step is that speech
recognition gives us a transcript of what
you just said,
so we need to send it to Google Translate
to actually
translate it.
It is just done using plain code.
So no
closed here.
Once you have the original transcript and
it is translation, you can send it to the
other person.
And the cool thing is that there is WebRTC
data transfer
for that, so you don't need any servers, so
normally
you'd send it using Ajax or web sockets or
something
like that, but in the case of WebRTC you have
direct
connection with the other person.
We don't need any
server for that.
So, using the data channels, this is
really easy.
You have just one to send directly to all,
you specific the channel name, payload name
which is
basically what you're sending, and the data
itself.
Yeah, that's it.
So the last step is, so we already
have the original end translator transcript
on the other
side, and now it is time to read it out loud
and we use
again API for that.
It is called synth API, it looks
like that.
You have this really strange object, I just
have to instantiate, the language, the message
itself,
and then you have this, and then you have
this speak
method where you have to just pass this object
to, and
that's actually, as you can see, hopefully
the
individual steps of it are really simple,
in the real
application there is a bit more code, for
example, for
call handling for handling language switches
and so on,
but yeah, that's actually the core of it.
There is not
really that much code in the application.
If anyone is
interested in the actual code, I'll give the
link to the
code at the end of the talk.
The second part, I'd like
to give you a very brief introduction into
web speech
API, I just actually wanted to mention two
things.
So
the first thing is that web speech API recognition
has
two modes, the first one is one shot, and
the second one
is continuous.
In the one shot mode, in the speech
recognition, the algorhythmic will stop when
you want,
which is great for giving commands and that's
the mode
used in my application.
The other mode, which is more
interesting, is the continuous mode and basically
it
will even if you make a pause, it will just
continue to
work, at least in theory.
So this one is great for
dictating stuff, or for my application, with
me at
least, where users -- two users have a conversation.
Unfortunately it doesn't really work that
well.
And
I'll tell why really soon.
The second thing is that
according to the spec, the API itself is like
agnostic
of the underlying speech recognition implementation,
so
it basically doesn't implement -- it doesn't
specify how
the speech recognition should work.
And you can have
speech recognition on server, or on the client.
So in
Chrome, it uses Google services, so it is
on the server,
but it could be done locally.
So while the speech API
is really awesome, it has some issues.
So if you'd like
to experiment with it, I'll just, you know,
briefly
describe what the issues are, so at least
you know what
to expect.
So the first issue is that the speech
recognition will stop if you talk for too
long, I'm not
sure what the exact limit is, but if you talk
for a
minute or over a minute, it will stop.
You'll get abort
event, and yeah, that's actually -- the second
issue is
actually quite the opposite.
It will stop if you don't
talk for as long.
I'm talking about the continuous mode
which should handle pauses, but if you will
make long
enough pause, it will just stop.
Again, you'll get
abort event, and there is a work around these
issues.
I
mean, you can wait for the abort event and
just call
start again, but unfortunately, in some cases,
after you
call start, it will abort again and it will
end up with
this, which makes the application unstable
and actually
that's the reason why my application doesn't
use the
continuous mode.
So the most important issue, I think, is that
web
speech API doesn't work with WebRTC media
streams, so
the thing is the specification was created
probably
before WebRTC application, so that's why it
doesn't
mention anything about media streams, and
it means that
the web speech API can only recognise input
from your
own mic, nothing else, really, and that causes
a lot of
issues.
So the first thing is that, for example, in
my
application, which is WebRTC, and web speech
recognition
API, it will ask you twice for your mic, which
is really
confusing for users.
So once it will ask for WebRTC,
the second time with the web speech RPI, but
the most
important thing is, like I said, it can only
recognise
what you're saying.
You can't get remote audio stream
from another person and just pass it into
web speech
recognition object, right.
So if you could do it, you
could basically just write an extension or
plug into any
web application and perform the whole recognition
of
whatever any other person has said on your
computer,
which would be really cool.
Another thing is I'm not
sure if you're aware, but using WebRTC you
can actually
make phone calls or make or receive phone
calls.
You
have to use gateway service, but it is possible,
and if
you could pass like remote audio to speech
recognition,
you could actually, for example, make an application
where you just call somebody, take audio from
them and
just pass it for speech recognition locally.
So it will
be pretty good for, for example, people with
hearing
loss, which could basically create a transcript
on the
phone call on the fly.
So yeah, unfortunately it
doesn't work, but like I said, this web speech
spec
doesn't really mention anything about it,
but actually
it would be really easy to extend the specification
without breaking it down.
That's it.
You just have to
pass audio stream to this speech recognition
object and
it could just work.
So that's actually what Firefox is
doing right now.
They're extending, it has been at
least, extending this API a bit without breaking
it
actually, I just was told that it should work
in Firefox
2.5, so hopefully it will sync soon.
And like the most
obvious reason why this API is not really
more popular,
it works only in Chrome.
And the issue is that it is
not even like all chrome, desktop and mobile.
The issue
is that for example there is a small bug in
mobile
version of Chrome which doesn't allow you
to use speech
recognition if you're WebRTC at the same time.
So
unfortunately my app won't work on android.
But what can we do about these issues?
I mean, the
first is we can ask them nicely to update
the spec, ask
Google to fix the implementation, or we could
ask
another browser mender to actually implement
the API.
And while the speech recognition itself is
really
complicated problem, the technology is not
really an
issue here.
Personal assistance or virtual assistance
is really popular lately, and it turns other
that every
browser actually has some implementation of
it.
So
Google obviously has Google Now, Apple has
Siri, Firefox
actually doesn't have anything, but they are
using a
library called Pocket Sphinx, which does speech
recognition locally on the device.
But there is also
another way.
We don't really need to wait for a browser
vendors, so you probably remember this one.
Right?
So
all the time I'm talking about making implementation
of
the API, but it is actually possible to create
a virtual
library that will have exactly the same API
as web
speech API and just would use some third-party
service
to perform the speech recognition, or do it
locally.
So
again, like I said, the speech recognition
is like
really complex and hard problem, but again,
as it turns
out, there are plenty of companies that are
actually
happy to write.
So Facebook has recently announced
Facebook M assistant, yet another -- they
also obviously
have technology for speech recognition.
There is
another assistant called hound by SoundHound.
I'm not
sure if you have heard about it but it looks
promising,
BaiDu has announced one recently, there are
some other
companies that do speech recognition, obviously,
and
there is also we've just seen a demo, there
is IBM
Watson which also has API performing speech
recognition.
Finally, there is an interesting project called
Pocket
Sphinx JS which actually uses the library
that is used
by Firefox and it compiles it using scripts
into
JavaScript and this actually provides the
fully
functional speech recognition library in your
browser
and actually in any browser that supports
WebRTC.
It
doesn't have to support speech recognition.
So that's actually it.
I kind of hope that you saw
that, you know, the whole implementation wasn't
really
that hard.
Each step was really easy.
You can see we
have today's browsers are really powerful
and I strongly
encourage you to maybe instead of writing
yet another
framework just try to experiment with them.
Also I kind
of hope that once Firefox actually releases
a version
that of their browser that has a web speech
implementation API, I mean web speech API
implementation, it will just become more popular.
My
name is size a Szymon and I work with these
companies.
That's all.
Thank you.